steven guilbeault le ministre de
l'environnement et du changement
climatique du canada est avec nous ce
soir bonsoir monsieur guilbeault mais ce
match est plié l'une des grandes
priorités dans discours du trône
aujourd'hui c'est vraiment la lutte
contre les changements climatiques qu'on
a parlé de il ya toujours des grands
énoncées dans un discours du trône mais
avait quand même des choses assez précis
sur la tarification du carbone sur le
sur les technologies propres également
sur le plafonnement et la réduction des
émissions de gaz à effet de serre dans
le pétrole mais on va pas jusqu'à dire
là la baisse la production du pétrole
pourquoi on ne va pas jusqu'à dire ça
pour quelques raisons différentes
d'abord d'un point de vue fonctionnel ce
sont les provinces qui ont le pouvoir
d'utiliser d'exploiter ou non leurs
ressources naturelles s'est passé c'est
pas de ressources de la cour fédérale
par contre nous pouvons agir et la cour
suprême dans le code de la cause sur la
tarification carbone est très clair nous
pouvons agir sur la pollution au niveau
fédéral et ultime ans pour l'atmosphère
c'est ce qui compte parce que les
émissions de gaz à effet de serre baisse
ou diminue ou alors ce plafond là c'est
le seul secteur au pays où on met en
place un plafond ne fait pas pour
l'aluminium l'acier l'automobile est le
ciment on le fait pour propos secteur
énergétique du pétrole et du gaz parce
que c'est 25% des émissions ok le
déficit va atteindre 157 milliards en
2000 21 22 cette année
350 milliards l'année précédente votre
gouvernement bien sûr s'engage dans une
transition importante sur le plan
énergétique qui va quand même coûté cher
est-ce qu'on a les moyens de nos
ambitions
c'est une excellente question bon faut
bien voir évidemment que les vinyles
dépenses au cours des 18 derniers mois
et est beaucoup liée à la pandémie et
ses dépenses leur ont été appuyés par la
très grande majorité tous les partis
présents à la chambre des communes de ne
pas d'autre part nous sommes dans une
situation de pandémie mondiale par
définition de pandémie mondiale mais
cette situation économique là ce ces
défilés auxquels nous faisons face c'est
vrai aux états unis en europe au japon
et notre notre situation fiscale était
très bon avant la pandémie comparaître
vivement tout le monde elle est encore
très bonnes c'est d'ailleurs pourquoi il
ya quelques jours un monde is a ordonné
une 4-3 au canada parce que malgré ses
dépenses importantes là que nous et bien
d'autres avons fait autour de la planète
notre situation fiscale demeure encore
très ambitieux mais en même temps dans
discours d'aujourd'hui on ne peut pas
parler de dettes on ne peut pas parler
de déficit et est ce que ça fait partie
des priorités du gouvernement que de
que de ramener l'équilibré budgétaire ou
en tout cas de réduire les déficits de
façon importante
je pense que vous avez vues dans le
dernier budget qui a été présentée par
ma collègue ma collègue la ministre il
aime que il ya effectivement un plan
pour pour le retour à un équilibre
budgétaire mais il est nous sommes très
très saisie de ça mais la priorité au
cours des derniers mois c'était d'aider
les canadiens et canadiennes d'aider les
entreprises d'aider les organisations et
dans certains secteurs on n'est pas
sorti de la pandémie je pense notamment
aux secteurs des arts et de la culture
où c'est encore très difficile donc il
ya encore besoin d'être gouvernementale
mais on en regarde ce qui se passe à
plus long terme et c'est une question
qu'on construite près d'un discours on a
parlé de transition qui passe par
l'acier par l'aluminium par l'automobile
par l'aéronautique vers où on veut
vraiment développer une production
propre donc on parle quand même monsieur
guilbeault de croissance de
développement économique vert on est pas
on n'est pas dans la décroissance la
non effectivement et je pense que le
canada est bien positionné dans certains
secteurs pour tirer son épingle du jeu
de cette économie lors du 21e siècle qui
sera une économie verte alors des
projets comme celui qu'il est qu'il ya
présentement au lac saint jean se
susurre a prévu un projet qui est déjà
en cours de développement pour faire de
l'aluminium presque sans émissions de
gaz à effet de serre et l'aluminium
canadien est déjà celui avec la plus
ferme en train carbone au monde et l'on
arriverait à faire encore quelque chose
d'encore plus intéressant d'un point de
vue de l'innovation et et
l'environnement nous avons fait nous
faisons des investissements très
importants dans le secteur de l'acier
notamment pour arriver à atteindre ce
genre d'objectif le secteur de
l'automobile au canada qui promet rage
vers l'électrification qu'il reflet
aussi d'un monde qui change au niveau de
l'automobile également
l'objectif est de transformer la société
canadienne pour se diriger
donc une transformation qui n'est pas
une réduction de production vous ne
voulez pas ralentir l'économie vous
voulez transformer la production la
croissance et le développement pour
qu'ils soient plus vert
exactement et c'est vrai pour l'ensemble
j'ai parlé de l'ontario j'ai parlé du
québec mais je pourrais parler de
l'alberta qui la province présentement
qui reçoit le plus d'investissements en
technologies propres et en énergies
renouvelables c'est pas au québec qu'on
voit ça c'est pas en colombie
britannique où même en ontario c'est
vraiment un albertain pourquoi parce que
pour développer plusieurs des nouvelles
technologies dont nous aurons besoin on
pense aux biocarburants par exemple
j'ai déjà visité à edmonton une
bioraffinerie donc une entreprise on
fait des bio carburants de la compagnie
québécoise enerkem ça ressemble
drôlement une raffinerie de pétrole
alors on ne le met on a des besoins en
terme de main d'oeuvre qui sont
semblables à ceux qu'on retrouve dans
une province comme l'alberta est ce que
l'aéronautique l'aviation il y avait le
patron d'airbus canada aujourd'hui qui
disait qu'il fallait arrêter de
stigmatiser l'aviation et de faire de
l'aviation bashing est-ce que l'aviation
fait partie de la solution ou peut faire
partie de la vie de la solution
notre défi c'est de transformer
l'ensemble des secteurs c'est pas de
dire bon ben c'est ça car là on voit les
aider à se transformer puis celui là on
va laisser de côté pour vol mobilier
pour barbara donné les gens qui sont
dans cette heure là nous nous déplaçons
nous avons des besoins de déplacements
notamment de l'aviation leur travaillons
avec les entreprises travaillant avec
les syndicats de façon à trouver des
solutions pour que ce secteur là comme
les autres diminue ses émissions de gaz
à effet de serre le positionnement est
quand même très clair monsieur
guilbeault merci beaucoup
merci à vous je dis au revoir merci au
revoir pour voir nos émissions en entier
rendez vous sur la chaîne i r d
[Musique]